hi I'm Kate and I am undateable in Los
Angeles this sums up about 90% of the
messages I get on dating apps while in
LA I set a simple sup and he said finger
your grapefruit it's quite the leap
unwilling to even consider the
possibility that maybe it's me I figured
somewhere in America I've got to be
dateable I'm gonna find that City we're
going to rate each city on the following
criteria number of matches overall price
of the city and is it a fun place to be
single in first up San Francisco the
land of tech tech land land of the app
my theory is that I will get more
matches in San Francisco and my hope is
that even if I don't it's still a fun
day to be single it and here there port
get ready to fly to the super disco to
hopefully get some dates open to all the
possible rejection
second we landed in San Francisco I
immediately started swiping I started
swiping right on just about everybody
except for people who look incredibly
creepy
I found that putting exactly what I'm
looking for in my bio it's helping me
get the matches that I want it if you
want a certain thing put it in your bio
that's what it's for it what's good and
then just let them come to you that stay
here out gaining am I gonna [ __ ] fall
in love right now I'm getting billion
messages this guy but we had a
delightful conversation I was like wow
this is gonna be easier than I thought
and then he goes what are your thoughts
on hug men listen do we want to do I
just I thought I felt weird you guys you
should get it while I was waiting for
all the date results to come in I
decided to go and ask some locals what
they thought about dating in San
Francisco here we are in San Francisco
at the most famous bridge that we can
afford to film in front of the Bay
Bridge
so we're gonna go and ask some people
what it's like to date in San Francisco
and hopefully get a date I don't know
we'll see what happens Oh judge bills I
am here with how would you describe
dating in San Francisco whole bunch of
sex not a whole lot of dates so I'm gay
San Francisco is like playground shag
people coming through all the time so
everyone is constantly like looking for
some
got it other city is a little calmer a
little more chance for a relationship
any tips for someone dating just for a
few days in San Francisco
you could be as honest and crude as you
want get on Grindr I made a mental note
to get onto Grindr and we moved on my
first date was with Mark at the Comstock
saloon thank you for having me man yeah
I was a little nervous for this date we
didn't grow up here no I did well I
moved here when I was 13 and then when
he showed up he was taller and
better-looking than I thought he was
going to be which made me even more
nervous yeah he's beautiful yeah the
being and like the pyramids were like
all these ancient
right there I was actually looking up
pictures of Egypt that was not just on
my phone I just want everyone to know
that I was not being rude yeah it was
really nice we agreed on those things if
that means that I we got like a couple
drinks shots the conversation kept going
you just felt like it building yeah [ __ ]
it
to everything agreeing to everything and
he got the second drink um
truth be told there wasn't the biggest
spark it was a good definitely good
icebreaker I was excited to see what
other dates were going to happen well
thank you so much this is a delight okay
the pleasure is all mine great go home
safely all right okay thank you
okay I think one of the reasons that
dating is so hard is that I'm I try to
be a really good date before I try to
like really connect with this person so
I sort of prevent bad dates by like
being a chameleon to whoever I'm near so
my goal for today is to not do that
though some blue things that I
definitely liked about internet dating
is that I could date embedded while I'm
bloated
[Music]
you think they'll notice I haven't
shaved my legs because I didn't and I
also get my razor also this doesn't know
I'd like my hair to look for today but
you know I just didn't bring a straight
there was do your thing I'm following
you the second date was with Nick at
Maryann's a speakeasy style bar get
alike no a password to get in
very cool very nice bar hey he'll be on
good how are you I'm there okay thank
you well thanks for coming on today wow
this is really fancy yeah what do you
like look for people what's your type
all right make it a really have a type
so you're totally honest I would pretty
much go up to anyone
yeah but also be really bad if the
person's shot I'm like yeah too much I
really appreciate when people call out
that something is awkward instead of
just plugging along like it's not
awkward and he was like oh this is kind
of weird I was like it is weird cuz it
is weird to date on camera and a date at
all it's just the whole thing's weird I
think good dates going on would you ever
consider dating someone working yeah I
mean it yeah I guess I didn't it's like
the best way to meet people that was
like at work or at some sort of like I'm
joined a rock climbing gym and that's my
hope is to meet someone there but it has
not happened a kickball we love you
agree would you prefer to have some okay
hey I haven't grown up yet
I'm good but where would you rather have
someone be like yeah did you have that
fear brother where it was like hey like
I'm video producers unemployed but yeah
if I'm in touch with my inner
got it so we think in touch with your
inner child is better than saying I'm
still a little kid this is we it's a
weird is it you gotta be selective when
you don't throw those words around
little kid in your tinder box yeah
creepy yeah we should totally hang out
if you have time and you feel like
hanging out with me again if I didn't
blow this you blew it
how'd I do sorry but you blew it give me
like it please leave you blew it I was
kidding
let's give you a great great if you were
gonna good are you kidding at the end of
your date so you're gonna grade your
date but honestly like hardcore games I
don't want a grade schooler time skip
one to ten I want to evaporate I think
you were you were fat in about a 1/8 and
now I'm I'm gonna have to knock you down
to 6-4 we're asking me to grade you you
know I can always live with the fact
that I I wasn't at some point oh my god
a 12 out of 10 so Wow no I feel like a
dick overall it was a good date I know a
good time thanks you know okay and
hopefully when you come back to SF hang
out yeah although you know All Right see
you later
see it before I work that she went in my
mind way better than last night last
night was cool but I felt like I wasn't
trying to hurt this time I was like
letting it be awkward where I needed to
be awkward
he was really nice so after the second
date we decided to go out and explore
the city to see if it was even a fun
city to be and it turns out it is what a
delight what do you guys like most about
San Francisco I love that diverse
community really wanted to set up shop
and stay there forever you guys go in
dates not really a lot of great
Instagram backgrounds here every which
way you look a lot of color there is a
nice little coffee shop mmm I can talk
about it all day what's it like in San
Francisco wow this is my favorite
intersection of any intersection
probably ever look at that place is
pretty I like that I want to go there my
third date was with Jade at the interval
the interval was a really great place
loved it very nice too poor great staff
very good drinks the date was well
you'll see hello okay thanks to see you
absolutely welcome have you been here
before no no it's my first time I'm just
saying feel like we should get a drink
first that's a great idea okay what do
you drink I'll do an old fashioned aha
so I have loan company and just decided
to bring it out here that's that's one
of my favorite things about usin that
Houston bird as you do really you know
sometimes you just don't connect at all
with someone I got all so have you been
on the internet dating for a while this
is my first Internet date actually
really yeah my okay you're so gullible
you're right I am going oh this is not
going well
this tooth sucks so I recently found out
that there are five pictures you could
use on your online dating profile that
will help you get matches it is you
doing something active you hang out with
friends to prove you have friends you
with an animal usually a dog you dressed
fancy and then one picture of you
dancing with either your mom or your
grandma something like that this guy had
four out of those five pictures and the
dog wasn't his now what was your worst
day worst day yeah was one time
out with this girl that was running for
BuzzFeed and I'm just getting there
sometimes you do run into people that
are only seeing you just because they
know that you have more money than them
and I'd like for you to buy everything
for them I've ran into one of those
recently like a few weeks ago and uh
yeah she was telling me how she wanted
sugar daddy and I told her chills like
as was that all you have to offer is
just a pretty face that didn't know I
mean that's not what I'm looking for
saying yeah of course I'm not trying to
yeah think of sugar baby
but yeah how much more time do we have
to be here it is 917 we do not have time
for law enforcement well needless to say
there wasn't gonna be a second date one
because I don't live in San Francisco
and two because we did not hit it off at
all
and I don't feel bad saying that
normally I would but I don't feel bad
saying that because he did in fact
unmatch me real soon after the date
after that date we decided to go to a
local bar to see if I could flirt with
people in person this was my nightmare
come here the makeout room I'm gonna go
in and we gradually
[Music]
blowing out in a different city and
flirting is I think easier than flirting
in the place where you live because you
could vacation flirt which is the the
best possible version of yourself
without ever having to back it up
long-term however it was like a Tuesday
night and they weren't bitin let me tell
ya
[Music]
it did not go as expected turns out I
actually might be better online than I
am in person I know your strengths yeah
I'm losing faith I'm gonna be alone
whatever so my fourth date was with
Riyadh at the aquarium very fun location
he was on shark tank and we went to the
aquarium that was on purpose it just so
happened that that was the time he was
free the same day that we're going to
the aquarium hello how's it going good
are you good if you're coming glad you
found the place yeah of course of course
good to see you UQ all right all right
right right you go to the yeah I want to
see some fish okay sushi you know that
kind of stuff gross
pretty what's your favorite fish to eat
I think tunas my favorite too spicy tuna
yeah okay good it's spicy too it's up
there yeah what's your favorite shrimp
tempura moody often dating yeah not
nothing really in the words yeah yeah
it's kind of more of a secondary thing
got it oh it's a type of shark maybe
look at the fins oh look do you want to
see what it's like to be in a fish tank
yeah let me get my head in that's cool
you look really small I do yeah I feel
small looks cool do you want a picture
it's gone yeah wasn't the best date we
didn't really mesh well you're just on
like two different planes really good
I'd love them you know goodness so
what's like an ideal date for you
something to break the ice like this hey
Julia wouldn't be with the camera I've
been in a shark tank before he was
literally I was just a bad joke
Oh sequels are my favorite until they
[ __ ] on you know I look well I mean yeah
sure yeah good luck
oh what's that do you see that thing but
it might be trash true true
might be it's like oh maybe a water
bottle or something yeah well this is
fun thank you it was fun glad we saw the
fish yeah
good date yeah it was pretty good what
do you think he was okay he talked a lot
about himself and then it really follows
their own
it's kind of awkward okay so we're on
the way back back to LA and it is how I
would write San Francisco number of
matches 245 how expensive wasn't it was
very expensive is it a good place to be
single yeah if you have a lot of money
San Francisco is great it wasn't perfect
I have more dates in three days and I
have in the past three months so I
learned a lot about how I present myself
physically I'm a little bit of a hunter
slouch
I need to sit up sit up straight I
closed myself off a whole lot and I make
rough faces
so I've where should we go next
maybe Seattle I was told Nashville I was
also told Butte Montana I'm really you
know what this point I'm fielding no
offers so you guys just let me know got
here in my mouth though that last bit
thanks for watching
you
[Music]